the Tennessee River is now a Chain of
Lakes changed from a flowing stream by
the construction of a series of dams the
nearest dam is near the confluence of
the Tennessee with the Ohio River and
creates Kentucky reservoir the largest
in the tennessee valley 184 miles long
with more than 2,000 miles of shoreline
the construction of the huge Kentucky
dam built for the storage of flood
waters for navigation and for the
production of electric power was
expected to bring about many biological
changes in the area one of which was the
creation of favourable conditions for
the production of Anopheles Quadra
maculatus the vector of malaria in the
southeastern United States this
reservoir was to be impounded in a
region where abundant vegetation and a
mild climate had long been associated
with the occurrence of malaria in
partially cleared and fully drained
bottomlands sloughs and swamps along the
Tennessee River
such areas subject to periodic flooding
quickly grow up in willows button balls
and Ligurian stands of annual plants
which create an ideal environment for
the production of anak alene mosquitoes
while reservoir improvement eliminates
many floodplain swamps and other
low-lying problem areas broad shallows
will be created in many localities along
the reservoir margin where vegetation
control will remain a problem of major
concern
detailed study of the topography of the
Kentucky reservoir region was the first
tip taken by the malaria control staff
of the Health and Safety Department in
the development of plans for malaria
control in the region the sanitary
engineer in charge of malaria control
together with the medical malaria gist
the biologists and others planned the
course of action for his specialists
trained in malaria control the 2,000
miles of shoreline presented numerous
challenging situations and many
troublesome spots where malaria had long
been endemic these had to be located
before malaria could be successfully
controlled on the reservoir
preliminary fieldwork included a
botanical reconnaissance of the
reservoir basin for mosquito production
is influenced by the types of plants
which occur in a potential breeding area
adult mosquito catching stations were
set up in barns where Anopheles
quadrille maculatus commonly rest by day
these stations were periodically visited
to obtain an index of mosquito
population which served as a guide in
program planning all likely breeding
places were located and charted
particular attention was given to
extensive swamp lands and other marginal
depressions which might hold water after
in poundage periodic dipping for larvae
in likely breeding places provided
information which together with the
records of the adult catching stations
furnished a base of reference concerning
the malaria potential before creation of
the reservoir
health officers in the region
participated in program planning by
providing information concerning past
outbreaks of malaria available morbidity
and mortality records were analyzed to
gain this information
families were informed of the importance
of the survey and usually responded
cheerfully to the requests for blood
films
the films were prepared by the health
department nurse who knew the residents
through previous contacts upon
completion slides were forwarded to the
laboratory for examination information
secured from adult mosquito catching
stations from larva dipping counts from
tabulations of aquatic plant life and
from malaria surveys was analysed
correlated and plotted on detailed
working maps when the field force
reassembled after the completion of
preliminary field appraisal experience
in the Tennessee Valley demonstrated the
futility of attempting to control an
awfully mosquito production in
reservoirs of this type entirely with
larvicides a new concept was developed
which involved the engineering
application of permanent works
the engineering project planning
division of the water control planning
department collaborated in the selection
of the type of engineering project best
suited for the permanent control of
problem areas located by the Health &
Safety Department staff where diking and
dewatering was selected as a means of
control
this division furnished cost appraisal
analyses and preliminary plans for dikes
pumps and pump houses 22 miles of dikes
were planned to cut off large flat areas
from the main lake assistance was also
given in planning the large-scale earth
movements required in filling and
deepening and in extensive drainage
projects involving the removal of more
than 2 million cubic yards of Earth
in many instances the Highway and
railroad division was able to relocate
railroads and highways within diked
areas this eliminated the necessity for
flat slopes and expensive rip-rapping
for protection of fields against wave
action the resulting savings in
construction and clearance costs more
than equal the cost of building the
dikes the reservoir clearance division
prepared the reservoir in accordance
with specifications based on the
impounded water regulations of the state
health department's many refinements and
reservoir preparation practices were
developed through close cooperation
between the malaria control staff and
the clearance division
the biological readjustment division is
interested in developing Fish & Wildlife
Resources just as the malaria gist is
interested in reducing mosquito
production by planning and working
together on problems evolving both
interests many of the apparent conflicts
between mosquito control and wildlife
conservation can be resolved malaria
control projects were reviewed with the
construction and maintenance division
for inclusion in the overall reservoir
construction
the regional Studies department reviewed
alternative plans for the use of
marginal lands in the reservoir area for
example the decision to protect the town
of Big Sandy against backwater by means
of a dyke was closely related to malaria
control plans for a nearby dewatering
project
it was proposed to limit human occupancy
of the restricted areas to the hours
between dawn and dusk when malaria
mosquitoes commonly do not bite this
however permitted normal agricultural
use
based on the findings of the field staff
in the reservoir area these proposals
were drawn up as a preliminary report
outlining a suggested malaria control
program embracing permanent shoreline
improvement measures in Kentucky
reservoir the field staff reviewed the
important features of the report in its
final form due to its size flat
topography and limited scope of water
level fluctuations expected during the
mosquito breeding season this reservoir
will present an unusually serious and
extensive malaria problem portions of
the reservoir cannot be effectively and
economically controlled to prevent
mosquito production by the usual
measures applied after impounding namely
the application of larvicides annual
growth removal and marginal drainage
maintenance approximately 1/3 of the
shoreline was classified as areas where
prolific production of mosquitoes was
expected to occur under conditions
difficult or impossible to control by
the usual methods it was for these areas
that permanent improvement measures were
proposed
estimates of the initial cost of these
projects diking and dewatering deepening
and filling land use restriction and
mosquito proofing with limited lava
Seidel operations and shoreline
maintenance when compared with the
initial cost of the usual control
measures indicated that a greater
capital investment would be required
however in the annual cost year after
year the economic value of the proposed
plan is seen in the difference between
three hundred and thirty three thousand
three hundred dollars and a hundred and
sixty five thousand five hundred and
eighty dollars or 167 thousand seven
hundred and twenty dollars in estimated
annual savings
so it was planned to do a better job at
a greatly decreased annual cost by using
permanent works
the director of health saw in the
proposed program the opportunity to
demonstrate the application of permanent
works in the control of malaria on
impounded water the proposal was in
agreement with the opinion of the board
of consultants who from time to time had
suggested that more economical and
permanent approaches the malaria control
should be formulated and applied on
impounded waters in lieu of less
effective methods involving high
repetitive costs the proposed plan was
carefully examined for agreement with
state regulations governing impounding
of water and forwarded to interested
agencies for their consideration and
criticism endorsement of the plan was
received from the State Department of
Health of Kentucky from the Surgeon
General of the United States Public
Health Service from the Tennessee State
Department of Public Health and from the
International Health Division of the
Rockefeller Foundation the proposed plan
for malaria control on the Kentucky
reservoir was submitted by the director
of Health through the general manager to
the TVA board of directors for approval
the director of health subsequently was
advised that the general manager and
Board of Directors approved the
principles for malaria control on
Kentucky reservoir which had been
developed over a period of four years of
the engineering biological and medical
study
and
initial steps in the preparation of the
reservoir includes taking the contour
marking the limits of the reservoir
normal pool elevation is marked is the
basic clearing line for applying
specifications for the removal of trees
and brush the distance to be cleared
beyond this line varies with topography
type of growth and exposure of the
future shoreline to wave action
most of the workmen were residents of
the area familiar with the use of timber
cutting tools from their boyhood days
various types of tools adapted to
specific operations were required at the
beginning of each day assignments were
made tools were selected as a men began
their work the underbrush was cut by one
crew to make it easier and safer for the
timber cutting crew which followed
felling of the larger trees as a
hazardous operation requiring skill and
constant precaution to assure safety
in some areas mules were used to drag
logs into the cleared area where they
were piled
along stream banks large trees were
dragged from the water's edge by
tractors with winch attachments
special bank machines developed within
the authorities were also used on this
type of operation
marketable timber was hauled to sawmills
and cut into lumber
on all operations care was taken to
provide the workmen with an ample supply
of safe drinking water paper cups were
provided at all times and only
chlorinated water was distributed at
regular intervals field tests for
residual chlorine were made a testing
solution was added to the sample then
checked against color standards to give
an estimation of the residual chlorine
these safety efforts resulted in a very
low accident frequency rate trees and
the upper limits of the fluctuation zone
of problem flats would cut level with
the ground
this not only facilitates the use of
power mowers in annual growth removal
operations but also reduces rerouting
because of their tendency toward
excessively sprouting willow stumps were
treated with Ann Arbor Seidel oil
we're ground conditions were suitable
for the use of heavy equipment timber
and brush were cut and especially
designed power rates were used to push
the cuttings into wind rows for burning
occasionally it was necessary to sever
large branches from the trunk and to cut
trees into two or three sections in
order to secure compact necessary for
burning no other manual work was
required the sweeping action of the
limbs and brushes they're pushed along
gives an unusually clean job the power
rake consists of a conventional
bulldozer with flexible teeth hung on
the blade and with supporting slides on
each margin to keep the blades at the
proper working elevation
the long wind rows of brush and trees
were allowed to dry thoroughly before
they were burned
in the final stages of burning smaller
power rights pushed the remaining
material together to assure complete
disposal
the end result of this operation is a
clean ground surface
both channels were marked in areas where
posting poundage Lava sidle operations
were anticipated locations for channel
markers were established by field
surveys plans for these channels were
coordinated with other reservoir
navigation aid the markers also provide
aid to fishermen and operators of small
recreation boats
drainage ditches were constructed in
order that swamps and other low-lying
areas along the margin of the reservoir
would be completely drained at the time
of low water levels or would fluctuate
freely with changing reservoir level
field surveys provided basic information
for the development of drainage plans
after drainage plans were approved
ditches were staked construction was
done usually with draglines
we're ditching was in wooded areas
stumps were removed by blasting the
shattered stumps were removed with the
aid of timber hooks attached to the
dragline
in swampy areas that draglines traveled
and operated on supporting math in some
situations drainage was required for
clearing or other construction work
which would have been impeded by
pondered water
final conditioning of the malaria
control fluctuation zone required the
removal of vegetation from a marginal
band which varied in width from a few
feet on steep banks to a wide belt in
the flats
we're topography the type of growth and
weather conditions permitted area
burning was utilized in marginal growth
removal some woody stands were burned
over but most area burning was over
grass covered flats in situations where
area burning could not be utilized hand
and machine cutting was used prior to
raking and burning immediately below the
margin of complete growth removal tall
vegetation extending into the
fluctuation zone was topped
in some cases mowers and teams belonging
to local farmers were utilized on the
growth removal operations team mowers
were especially useful on rough terrain
and in small areas tractor mowers cut
from two to four times as much per day
as team mowers and we used principally
and large flat areas
although low stumping added to the
initial cost of clearance in the
fluctuation zone the increased
effectiveness and economy of the mowing
operation an annual margin conditioning
repaid this additional expense hand
cutting was used we're more economical
methods could not be applied after
cutting the brush was piled for burning
to reduce man-hours required to clear
areas of heaviest regrowth and cutting
of sprouts was preceded by a brush
Harrow drawn by a bulldozer
after the Harrow had passed over the
area the remaining spots were cut by
hand and filed for burning
the piles of brush were burned
thus reservoir preparation provides a
clean Basin at the time of filling an
essential factor in the control of
malaria on impounded waters